[MUSIC]
I've worked at the same company for
my entire career,
which is completely unheard of.
It's been a fantastic learning
ground here at micron for me.
Over the years my career
progressed about six years ago,
I was asked to take on the head job for
HR and
then this last year I was
promoted to chief people officer.
One of my sources of inspiration or
at least thought leadership
are my professors from ACP.
But now I need to go and give back and
make sure I create the space and
the opportunity for
others to have that same experience and
invest in themselves and
learn and develop and grow.
So my team and I are working diligently on
making sure we're finding innovative ways.
To actually keep our
communities educated and
really democratize a lot of the learnings
that we offer inside of the company, and
make them available to
community members as well.
That's a tremendous opportunity for
us to take our digital skills curriculum,
and just make it available to anyone.
Who wants to take our curriculum.
That will not only certainly
help them prepare for
a career at micron, but
frankly will help them prepare for
any other career or
help them to see succeed in life.
[MUSIC]